- This program is presented by University
of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow us on Facebook
and Twitter to keep up with
the latest UCTV programs.
(gentle music)
- Today I have a special pleasure
of introducing Charles McCurdy.
I'll say three or four things about him.
First we're at the University
of California Berkeley
and we're very happy to
say that our speaker today
is a graduate of the University
of California at San Diego.
And he went on and did his doctorate
at the University of
California at San Diego.
And then not being the purist
that I thought he might be
he didn't stay for postdoctoral
work there he went to Yale,
for Yale Law School where he
was in a very famous program
that was run by Stanton
Wheeler at the Yale Law School
on Law Society studies.
And then he went on to
the University of Virginia
where he has been teaching
for close to 40 years.
And he has a remarkable
wonderful reputation
for undergraduate, PhD and law teaching.
And he's a professor of law and of history
at that institution and he
is renowned in the profession
of legal history and
Constitutional History.
Not only for his own wonderful work
but for the way he has trained
so well so many students.
Possibly more than any other individual
directing PhD programs in America.
I think that's actually,
that's an accurate statement.
If not he's certainly
way up there in numbers
and certainly very far up
there in the distinction
of those who work with him.
The last thing I should
speak of is his scholarship.
He has a remarkable record.
His early work was on Stephen J. Field,
the conservative California justice
who went on to Washington to become
for a long period of decades.
A key member of a court
that was moving more
and more toward a conservative
and regulatory pro-business position.
And for historically Field had been seen
as a knee-jerk conservative
who just gave business
community what it wanted.
But Charles McCurdy's work
changed that picture radically
and gave a much more complete picture
of what judicial conservatism was like
in the late 19th century in the large.
And it was a much more
complicated phenomenon.
And nobody in the field
has been able to write
the way people were writing
back in 60s about that court
or about judicial
conservatism and it's largely
if not to say exclusively is
the result of his early work.
And then he moved from
that into larger studies.
Studies on a larger
canvas of property law,
anti-trust, the police power and Taxation.
And in general one can
say as he's described
in the publicity that
came for this lecture.
He's been interested in the
relationship of ideology,
economic change and political movements
and has given us a very rich picture
of the dynamics of change
in the legal system
as a working system as well
as in what we call the law.
The narrower sense jurisprudence
and theory and courts.
And he among his many publications,
he has continued to publish
over the years on Stephan Field.
He did a another
path-breaking work on Field's
jurisprudence on the California Court,
which really made us all
think very differently
about property law.
Because he found and described brilliantly
how the court was
allocating property rights.
And playing a role in setting priorities
among mining, agriculture,
commerce and other sectors.
So again it's a terrific
legacy in the study
of American legal and constitutional
history that he's left.
And he did more than anyone
I think to open up the field
in very new rich way of
California law historically.
He then turned east and did a study
of the anti-rent movement in New York,
which was a similar kind of study
in terms of looking at
a very radical ideology
that concerned property rights.
And the inheritance in an
area of upstate New York
of essentially medieval tax claims
on servitude claims on the land.
And there was a very dramatic uprising
and he wrote a really big book,
a very big book on all the aspects of this
in the way I've just discussed, sorry.
In the way I've just discussed
and it was richly rewarded.
Because every three years a prize called
the Order of the Coif prize
is given for the best book
in law over a three-year period.
And he and another
historian shared that prize.
When you think about
the outpouring of books
and the frenzy over originalism
and all the rest that's
going on in recent years
this was a wonderful achievement.
And everyone in the field of legal
and constitutional
history is indebted to him
for having conquered all the prejudices
of a conservative bar in recognizing
the importance of this
kind of scholarship.
So welcome back to the
University of California
especially to Berkeley, Charles,
where you taught first semester
to the benefit of our students.
He actually took my courses
they didn't want me back,
students wanted just have him stay.
And it's just good to have you back
and we look forward to your lecture
which is on America's first war on terror.
Jeffersonian period appropriately enough
and concerning constitutional debate
of the Alien and Sedition Acts.
Charles McCurdy.
(applause)
- Oh come along everybody.
- Well thank you very much
for that warm introduction.
He didn't say what's
probably the most important
connection between us.
He directed my PhD dissertation
at the University of
California San Diego in 1966.
And has been a shameless a
promoter of my career ever since.
(audience laughs)
And I am forever grateful to him for that
and for also whatever part he played.
I know others, I know Waldo Martin
were on the on the committee.
And this place has always
been regarded by me,
a native California and
I grew up in Pasadena,
as the Mecca of academic life.
The Mecca of learning and scholarship
in the whole country.
And to come back under
these auspices today
is, well it's very exciting.
During the first decade of governance
under the Constitution
of the United States,
the young Republic confronted
a foreign policy crisis
that fractured the body
politic and produced
an age of political violence in America
as well as in Europe.
The reign of terror in
revolutionary France
sparked the crisis.
And the ensuing wars of
the French Revolution,
which lasted from 1793 to
1815, sustained the crisis.
President George Washington
issued a neutrality proclamation
in April of 1793.
But the American people were not neutral.
Federalists just despised
the godless bedlam in Paris
and prayed for fervently
for a British victory
over French anarchy.
As feelings heightened Republicans
were just as attached to the
cause of revolutionary France.
And his feelings heightened
the partisan language
of politically active Americans
grew increasingly strident and extreme.
One theme common to everyone's talk
was the fragility of
Republic's in a hostile world.
And so Republicans described
the Federalists in power
not only as Anglophiles
but also as monarchists
or monocrats, who intended to subvert
the Republicans state of
Liberty and not only in America
but everywhere in the world.
Fantastic motives were ascribed
to every federalist
initiative in the Congress
and in Atlantic diplomacy.
Federalists responded in kind.
They not only denounced
the Jacobin members
of the Republican opposition
but also insisted often and vehemently
that political opposition
when concerted and organized
was equivalent to subversion.
And this was especially true
if it were orchestrated
by a foreign power.
And as the nation inched
toward what we now call
the quasi-war with France in 1798.
Congress translated into law
the Federalists' claim
that Republican opposition
had put the very Republic in peril.
And so they passed the Sedition Act,
which is the heart of my lecture today.
The Sedition Act made it a federal crime
and I quote, "To write,
publish, utter or print
"any false scandalous
and malicious writing
"against the United
States or the President
"of the United States or
either house of the Congress
"of the United States, with the intent
"to excite against them the hatred
"of the good people of the United States
"or to stir up sedition among them."
Now the Sedition Act has
the dubious distinction
of being the only statute
enacted by Congress
in the 18th century to be
declared unconstitutional
by the Supreme Court of the United States
in the 20th century.
In a case called New
York Times and Sullivan
decided in 1964 Justice William
Brennan performed the deed.
And there established what he called
the central meaning of
the First Amendment.
The central meaning of the First Amendment
he said as he (garbled audio) old statute
unconstitutional he said,
that central meeting
was that debate on public issues
should be uninhibited,
robust and wide open.
And it may well be what will be included
are vehement, caustic and sometimes
unpleasantly sharp attacks on government
and public officials.
Now at first glance at
least Brennan's description
of the central meaning of
the First Amendment in 1965,
sounds very much like John
Adams defense of free government
in his dissertation on
the cannon and feudal law
published in 1765.
Behind Parliament's claim
to tax the inhabitants
of the British colonies Adams wrote
during the Stamp Act crisis of 1765,
lay the divine miraculous
origin of government
with which the priesthood had
enveloped the feudal monarch
in clouds and mysteries.
The thing said Adams had
always been different
in Massachusetts.
Its government was founded on knowledge
generally diffused through
the whole body of the people.
Let every sluice of knowledge
be opened and flowing,
said Adams in 1765.
Let us dare to think and
speak and think and write.
I said think twice, one of them was read.
Let us dare to read and
think and speak and write.
The irony of course is that in 1798,
President John Adams signed
a Sedition Act into law.
And there's more.
Neither Adams nor the house
and the Senate majorities
who voted for it or the
Supreme Court justices
who sustained it against
constitutional attack
13 different times between 1798 and 1801
doubted the competence of Congress
to make seditious libel a federal crime.
In their view the Sedition
Act was fully warranted
by the Constitution of the United States.
Now describing how Adams
and the Federalists
reached this conclusion is my
first task in this lecture.
Three components of
the Federalist argument
require attention.
First the Federalists had an argument
about the scope of the First Amendment's
guarantee of a free press.
Second the Federals had an argument
about the inherent powers
of the national government.
And third the Federalists had an argument
about the coextensive relationship
between the federal legislative power
and the federal judicial power.
Now as I reconstruct this Federalist view
I hope that you will be impressed
by its logical coherence
even if you aren't persuaded
by the arguments themselves.
My second task is to account
for the nature and scope
of the Republican critique
of the Sedition Act.
Culminating in the famous Virginia
and Kentucky resolutions of 1798.
And two years later in
Thomas Jefferson's victory
over Adams in the election of 1800.
A victory that Jefferson
never ceased to call
the revolution of 1800.
It follows that my third
task is to describe
the ramifications of
that revolution of 1800
for American constitutional politics.
And specifically for the
freedom of the press,
for the Federalist
doctrine of inherent powers
and for the Federalist idea of coextensive
legislative and judicial power.
In other words I don't need to explain
whether the election of 1800
generated a constitutional revolution
as well as a political revolution.
And if it did just how
extensive or how limited
are these constitutional
changes turned out to be.
Now along this route it's my intention
to establish some larger claims
about constitutional thought,
constitutional practice
and constitutional change in
the United States history.
But you'll have to be patient.
Historians have a penchant
for telling stories
that move from the
particular to the general.
Rather than the general and the particular
and history has been my principle
discipline for as long as I can remember.
So the Federalist argument
on freedom of the press.
For Adams and his friends the Sedition Act
did not abridge as the First
Amendment says it must not,
freedom of the press at all.
Because at common law
the freedom of the press
had been understood
for more than a century
as the right to publish
without prior censorship
by government officials.
Prior restraint of
publication was forbidden.
But freedom of the press
did not entail immunity
from subsequent prosecution.
For licentiousness,
seditious or subversive words
that excited the people and inclined them
to subvert the authority or rule
of duly constituted public officials.
In other words the Federalists subscribed
to what we now call the
Leonard levy thesis.
Named for the great civil libertarian
and historian of American
law who recovered
and reconstructed the Federalist argument
about freedom of the
press in the early 1960s.
May be pointed out that there was little
or no evidence suggesting that the framers
of the Constitution free press clause
intended to supersede the common law.
And he insisted that there
were substantial evidence
that they did not intend to do so.
In Pennsylvania and
Massachusetts for example,
there have been successful prosecutions
for seditious libel in the state courts
as late as 1791 despite the
guarantee of a free press
in the Constitution's of
Massachusetts and Pennsylvania.
Everywhere in revolutionary America
Levy maintained noisiest
defenders of a free press
asked only that the principles advocated
in the famous trial of John Peter Zenger
in early 18th century New York
be fulfilled and followed.
That is those principles
were truth as a good defense
in all actions of seditious libel.
And the jury's right not
just its latent power
to make determinations
of law as well as fact
in all trials for seditious libel.
And during the 1790s
there'd been some movement
in that direction.
The legislature of Pennsylvania
incorporated the Zenger principles
into its statute law in 1790.
Kentucky and Delaware
followed suit in 1792.
Thomas Jefferson, we finally got him in.
Thomas Jefferson had embraced
a qualified Zanger position
in the draft of the Virginia Constitution
which he proposed in 1783.
Here's what Jefferson wrote
this is his free press clause.
"Printing presses shall be
subject to no other restraint
"than libelness to legal
prosecution for falsehoods
"printed and published."
Now 15 years later Adams
and the Federalists
went further than Jefferson
had dared to go in 1783.
The Sedition Act of
1798 expressly provided
that truth would be a permissible defense
in a prosecution under the statute.
And it provided that the
jury would have control
over both law and fact in all trials
under this Sedition Act.
The Sedition Act said
Leonard Levy paraphrasing
Gilbert and Sullivan was quote,
"The true embodiment of
everything excellent."
It was that is,
it was the very epitome
of libertarian thought in 1798.
Now claiming that the
Sedition Act did not violate
the First Amendment as the Federalists did
was not to establish that
it was constitutional.
Adams and his friends
had to show that Congress
was competent to enact it
even though article one
of the Constitution did
not and does not enumerate
a power to regulate the press.
Whether to protect national security
or for any other purpose.
But the Federalists were good lawyers
and there were two
interlocking arguments at hand
for them to bootstrap into a claim
that Congress could enact as the statute.
The first had been
pioneered by James Wilson.
A great Federalist who ends up being
in the federal judiciary in the 1790s.
James Wilson of Pennsylvania.
Now in 1781 he pioneered
it all the way back
into the Articles of Confederation.
In 1781 shortly before
Congress voted to charter
the Bank of North America
Wilson rose to contest the claim
that Congress had no
power to pass such a law
because no Clause of the
Articles Confederation
authorized Congress to
create corporations.
And besides the Articles
Confederation stipulate
that quote each state
retains its sovereignty,
freedom and independence and every power,
jurisdiction and right which
is not by the Confederation
expressly delegated to the United States
in Congress assembled.
So Wilson faced what seemed
to be a double whammy.
There was no enumerated power for Congress
to create a bank and the Constitution
or Articles of
Confederation had a coupling
like the Tenth Amendment
only it said expressly.
Well Wilson had no problem claiming
that the bank was constitutional.
The article just quoted from
the Articles Confederation.
He swept aside as entirely
irrelevant to the question.
Because in as much as no
state could exercise any power
or act of sovereignty extending
over all the other states
or any of them, it followed that the power
to incorporate a bank
commensurate to the United States
was not an act of sovereignty or a power.
Which by the second article must expressly
be delegated to Congress by that body.
In other words since none of the states
could create a National Bank,
the reserve powers of the
states weren't affected
by the fact that the Congress
might be able to charter one.
"To many purposes," he said,
"The United States are to be considered
"as one undivided nation and is possessed
"of all the rights and power
"and properties by the law
of nations incident to such."
It followed he said and again I'm quoting,
"That whenever an object
occurs to the direction
"of which no particular state is competent
"the management of it
must necessarily belong
"to the United States
in Congress assembled."
Now applying Wilson's reasoning
to the Sedition question was a cinch.
And one Federalist Statesman
after another did so
on the floor of Congress
and in the pamphlet war
that followed the introduction and passage
of the Sedition Act of 1798.
That's because the law of
nations is the law of nature
applied to political states.
And the first law of nature is the right
of self-preservation.
And self-preservation it was said,
require this suppression of sedition
which undermined the people's
confidence in their government
by vilifying public servants
or condemning their acts.
Finally no particular
state had jurisdiction
over sedition against the United States
or against United States officials.
So just as murder on the
high seas was of necessity,
a question for United States
law and United States courts,
so was sedition against the United States.
In each instance, Congress
exercised powers or properties
that were incident to national
States by the law of nations.
And in each instance Federalists
argued national action
did not encroach on any right, sovereignty
or power reserved to the states.
Now these are the essential elements
of the inherent powers doctrine.
Now the Federalists
offered one more argument
to reinforce the doctrine
of inherent powers.
This was drawn from Federalist number 80,
the Federalist Papers from
Publius's 80th number,
written by Alexander Hamilton in 1788.
"If there are such things
as political axioms,"
Hamilton wrote, "The propriety
of the judicial power
"of a government being
coextensive with its legislative
"may be ranked among the number."
So what's this coextensive power concept?
It means that if Congress had jurisdiction
to establish an offense,
the federal courts must have
jurisdiction to try the offense
and to enforce the penalty.
By the same token if the
federal courts had jurisdiction
to hold a trial and to enforce a penalty,
then Congress must have
jurisdiction to abrogate the offense
or to modify it and to fix
a new and different penalty.
"Judicial power and legislative power
"want the maxim or axioms," said Hamilton
"had to be coextensive."
Now section 11 of the
Judiciary Act of 1789,
which created the rules and procedures
and structures of the federal judiciary.
Section 11 a clause the federal courts
with jurisdiction over all
offenses that were quote,
cognizable, by the
United States of America.
Cognizable.
So what sorts of offenses
had been cognizable
that is subject to federal jurisdiction
when Congress passed the
Sedition Act in 1798.
One class of federal crimes included
acts that had been prohibited
by federal statutes.
These included bribery of United
States customs collectors.
Counterfeiting United States bonds
and murder on the high seas.
But a second equally
important class of cognizable
federal offenses included all
kinds of common law crimes
that Congress had not forbidden
but were not cognizable
in the courts of any particular state.
So in the United States
Circuit Court for Pennsylvania,
a guy named Gideon Henfield was indicted
at common law for joining a
French privateering expedition
in violation of President Washington's
neutrality proclamation.
A diplomatic official from
Genoa was tried and convicted
at common law for sending
threatening letters
to the British Minister
with a view to extortion.
And the Philadelphia businessman
was tried and convicted
at common law for attempting to bribe
the United States commissioner of revenue
into awarding him a contract
for the construction
of a lighthouse on Delaware Bay.
Nor was that all.
Three different United
States circuit courts
handed down indictments at
common law for seditious libel
before the Sedition Act became law.
Samuel J. Cavil, which
is the building I teach
in the University of Virginia
is named for him, Cavil Hall.
Samuel J. Cavil who was
Jefferson's congressman,
a congressman from Charlottesville.
He was indicted by the
feds in Richmond, 1797.
Benjamin Beech editor of a
newspaper called the Aurora
was indicted by the feds
in Philadelphia in 1797.
And John Daly Burke,
editor of a journal called the Timepiece
was indicted by the feds in New York City.
The reasoning of these indictments
was since federal courts
had jurisdiction of such
offenses at common law,
and Congress's power were coextensive
with the federal judiciaries,
congress certainly had the
power to enact a statute
that defined the crime
with greater precision
and enlarged the rights
available to defendants
at common law.
And this is precisely
what the Sedition Act
of 1798 achieved.
Section one defined the offense.
Section two made truth a good defense
and authorized the jury to
consider questions of law
as well as questions of fact
when deliberating on their verdict.
Now I've said that the
inherent powers argument
and the coextensive powers argument
had an interlocking quality.
And this is because the power claimed
for Congress by Wilson,
and for the federal courts
in the common law crime
cases had the same foundation
and the same built-in
limitation on federal power.
The foundation was the idea
that pre-existing bodies
of law, the law of nations
in the one instance
the Wilson argument.
And the common law in the other.
The common law crimes argument,
legitimated action by
government authorities.
And the built-in limitation
was that the idea
that Congress and/or the federal courts
could legitimately claim
jurisdiction to act,
if and only if the subject
matter at issue was beyond
the purview of the
several states or any one
of the several states.
Federalists seem to have taken for granted
the resulting constraints on
the constructive amplification
of national power arising
from the doctrines
of inherent powers and the
doctrine of coextensive powers.
One thing however is certain
and that is that Jefferson
and the Republicans either did not grasp
the Federalist position or
they deliberately distorted it
in the rancorous
constitutional controversy
that generated the revolution of 1800.
Now the campaign against the Sedition Act
began at the moment
the bill was introduced
in the House of Representatives.
The alarm was sounded of
course by Thomas Jefferson,
vice president of the United States
as well as the Republican
Party's acknowledged leader.
"If this goes down," he wrote,
sounds very 21st century.
"If this goes down we shall
immediately see attempted
"another act of Congress
declaring that the president
"shall continue in office for life.
"Reserving to another
occasion the transfer
"of the succession to his
heir and the establishment
"of the Senate for life."
Was Jefferson serious?
Could monarchy be established
under our Constitution
by the amplification of
Congress's granted powers
and the nature of federal jurisdiction.
Well Jefferson apparently thought so.
I think he exaggerated a bit though.
If in 1798 anything seemed possible
with a mode of constitutional construction
grounded on the law of nations
and the English common law.
Both of which presuppose the legitimacy
of both monarchy and aristocracy.
Now James Madison was
ordinarily less impulsive
than his Virginian partner in politics
and more inclined to use
circumspect language.
Still the fourth Virginia
resolution of 1798
relied on the same slippery slope
and the same destination
posited by Jefferson.
Here's what Madison
said, he said, he wrote,
"That the General Assembly
expressed deep regret
"that indications have
appeared of a design
"to destroy the meaning and effect
"of the particular
enumeration and to consolidate
"the states by degrees
into one sovereignty.
"The obvious tendency and
inevitable result of which
"would be to transform the
present Republican system
"of the United States into an absolute
"or at best a mixed monarchy."
That's James Madison.
Jefferson and Madison had
been down this road before.
In 1791 they stood arm and
arm against consolidation
during the bank debate and they'd lost.
But this time the chances of
victory seem much greater.
They were up against John Adams
instead of George Washington.
What is more Federalist
arguments about inherent powers
and coextensive powers
seem much more vulnerable
than Alexander Hamilton's
artful deployment
of the Necessary and Proper
Clause in the bank controversy.
Consequently the Republicans assailed
from the very outset first
the notion that Congress
could exercise anything so
fuzzy as inherent powers.
They assailed the idea
that the Constitution
authorized federal courts to adjudicate
criminal cases at common law.
And they insisted that
Federalist claims to the contrary
put the very federal structure
of the Union into jeopardy.
The outstanding republican
performance in this vein
was Madison's in his famous 1800 report
to the Virginia legislature.
Article one of the Constitution
which enumerated powers
of Congress he wrote, "Was
logically incompatible
"with the notion that
the common law was part
"of federal law.
"Because the authority of Congress
"was necessarily coextensive
with the federal judiciary."
So he accepted the premise
of coextensive powers,
"To hold that federal courts
had cognizance of matters
"as vast and multifarious
as those in the common law
"would invariably overspread
the entire field of legislation
"and sap the foundation
of the Constitution
"as a system of limited
and specified powers."
Madison saw the common law
as a lever for Congress
to enact statutes on
all matters whatsoever.
Now the principle of states
rights cut a much larger figure
in the Republican appeal of 1798 to 1800,
abandoned the first amendment.
Still the Sedition Act
brought the relationship
between free government and a free press
into sharper focus than ever before.
A focus that produced
what Leonard levy called
a new libertarianism.
Now the major premise of
the new libertarianism
was that the common law of seditious libel
was incompatible with the
republican form of government.
Pamphlets by George Hay and Tunis Wortman
a couple of fellows from New York City,
pointed out the common law had developed
in a nation where the legitimacy
of public authority flowed
from a compact between
the ruler and the ruled.
Between the sovereign and the people.
In England the crime of seditious libel
protected the authority,
dignity and exalted position
of the sovereign.
But such an offense made
no sense, they argued,
in the United States because
here sovereignty resided
in the people themselves
and public officials
were rightfully regarded
as the mere servants
of their Republican masters.
Madison grasped this claim
and turned it brilliantly
to Republican advantage
in the Virginia report
in the spring of 1800.
"The people, not the
government," he wrote,
"Possess the absolute
sovereignty in America.
"And it followed that
rights here are secured by
"not by laws paramount to
prerogative but by constitutions
"paramount to laws."
It followed that the
American idea of a free press
was very different from that
postulated in the common law.
"The crabbit doctrine of no
prior restraint," said Madison
"Can never be admitted
in a republic since a law
"inflicting penalties
on printed publications
"would have a similar effect
with the law authorizing
"a previous restraint on them.
"It would seem a mockery to say
that no law should be passed
"preventing publications from being made
"but that laws might be
passed for punishing them
"in case they should be made."
Thus were born two observations
that figured prominently
in the First Amendment
jurisprudence of William Brennan
and the case of New York Times
in Sullivan in particular.
The idea that libel law has a tendency
to follow self-censorship and
the resulting chilling effect
on the Free Press on free
expression is incompatible
with the Republican form of government.
Now the Sedition Act
contained a sunset clause,
which means that this
lecture will eventually
get to a sunset.
It expired by the acts own
term on March the 3rd, 1801.
24 hours late Thomas
Jefferson was inaugurated
as the third President
of the United States.
Jefferson dared say nothing
about the sedition question
in his inaugural address, choosing instead
to hold out an olive
branch to the Federalists
with the famous quote,
"We are all Republicans,
"We are all Federalists."
But soon afterward Jefferson pardoned
all those who had been
convicted under the Sedition Act
and quietly dismissed the
prosecution still pending
against journalist, Republican
journalist James Duane.
"I discharged every
person under punishment
"or prosecution under the Sedition Act."
Jefferson wrote to
French shortly afterward,
"Because I considered
and now consider that law
"to be a nullity.
"As absolute and palpable a nullity
"as if Congress had
ordered us all to fall down
"and worship a golden image.
"And that it was as much my
duty to arrest its execution
"as it would have been to
rescue from the fiery furnace
"those that should have been cast into it
"for refusing to worship the image."
End of quote.
Yet for all this the revolution of 1800
did not necessarily mean the
end of trials for sedition.
Except for the new libertarians
who were a distinct minority in the party.
Republicans had condemned the Sedition Act
primarily on states rights grounds.
And Jefferson himself in an
1804 letter to Abigail Adams
flatly stated and I quote,
"while we deny that Congress
"have a right to control
the freedom of the press,
"we have ever asserted
the right of the states
"and their exclusive right to do so."
So was it possible that
the revolution of 1800
would mean nothing more
than Republican prosecution
of Federalists as a matter
of state law in state courts?
And what about the possibility
of prosecuting Federalists
for seditious libel at common
law in the federal courts?
The Sedition Act had expired
but federal jurisdiction
over common law crimes
cognizable by the United States.
Though much contested
during the campaign of 1800,
remained a live issue in our
law of the federal courts
and the federal system.
Now answers to the
questions came in due course
though often with a
surprising cast of characters,
a surprising plot or a
surprising they knew them all.
Consider first the resolution
of the free press question
in the state courts.
Ironically the leading case
pitted Federalists libertarians
against Jeffersonian Stan patters
on the common law of seditious libel.
When Jefferson became president,
his most powerful ally in New York
was Governor George Clinton.
And in 1803 Clinton's
administration obtained
a common law indictment
against Harry Croswell,
editor of an upstate
newspaper called The Wasp.
Croswell's crime was an
accusation that Thomas Jefferson
while serving as vice president
had paid another journalist
named James Callender to
denounce George Washington
as a traitor and a robber and a perjurer.
And John Adams as a
hoary headed incendiary.
In point of fact the
accusation for which Croswell
had been indicted was true.
James Callender was on
Thomas Jefferson's payroll
in 1798 and 1799 when Callendar
wrote those things in his newspaper.
Nevertheless the New York Trial Court
refused to allow the defendant
to subpoena witnesses
who could have established
the truth of the words.
And Chief Justice Morgan Lewis
who presided at the trial
and was the leading a
Republican who was end up
succeeding George Clinton
as governor of New York.
He instructed the jury
that at common law truth
was not a good defense in an
action of seditious libel.
Such that in New York at
least freedom of the press
was still defined as the
absence of prior restraint.
And the jury after hearing that charge
convicted Mr. Croswell.
Now on appeal to the New
York's highest court,
Croswell was represented
by Alexander Hamilton.
In vain did that the great
Federals leader urge the court
to grant Croswell a new trial
in the defense of truth.
So that the people might know
whether President
Jefferson had been guilty
of what Hamilton called
the foul act of libeling
President George Washington.
Hamilton maintained that freedom
of the press rightly
understood common law.
Quote, "Consists in the right
to publish with impunity,
"with good motives and
for justifiable ends
"though badly reflecting
on government, the Magestry
"or particular individuals.
Without proof of the
defendants actual malice,
not his presumed malice at Hamilton.
The journalist's statements
merited protection
from the state constitutions
guarantee of a free press.
Well it turns out that
Hamilton lost the battle
but won the war.
The two Republican judges
rejected his argument.
James Kent, a prominent Federalists
and Smith Thompson a former Federalist,
a former student of Kent's
voted for a new trial.
So the conviction was sustained
by an equally divided court.
But in 1805 the New York
legislature settled the matter
by enacting a statute
providing that every state
in the Union soon emulated
in one way or another.
This statute, the New York act of 1805,
shifted the burden of proof
and actions of seditious libel.
So that it became the state's obligation
not only to prove that
the material was false,
but also to prove that
it had not been published
for good reasons and justifiable ends.
And by this tortuous path
the new libertarianism
produced by the Sedition Act
of 1798 finally got translated
into effective protection of press freedom
as a matter of state law.
In fact the resulting legal regime lasted
until the civil rights era
generated new challenges
and a new doctrinal response to preserve
what Brennan called the central meeting
of the First Amendment.
What then about federal prosecutions
for sedition at common law?
The Supreme Court considered this question
in the remarkable case of
United States versus Hudson
and Goodwin decided in 1811.
At issue was the indictment
of two Hartford Connecticut newspaper men,
who had published an
article accusing Congress
of secretly appropriating
2 million dollars
at the request of President Jefferson
as a bribe of Napoleon.
Upon a division of the trial judges
over whether United States
Circuit Court had jurisdiction
the case was certified
to the Supreme Court.
And President Madison
Jefferson's successor
declined to defend the
indictment with either
a government brief or a government defense
of the prosecution in oral argument.
And so the result was predictable
Justice William Johnson,
a Jefferson appointee
dismissed the indictment
and held that federal courts
did not have jurisdiction
over crimes at common law now.
The decision in this
case Hudson and Goodwin
was extraordinary all the same.
It was remarkable first because of the way
Justice Johnson justified the result.
"Although this question is brought up now
"for the first time to
be decided by this court,
he said, "We consider it as
having been long since settled
"in public opinion."
I don't think the court
said that in a long time.
That this question had been
decided in public opinion.
It had been settled in other
words by the political upheaval
that Jefferson called
the revolution of 1800.
But that's not the only reason Hudson
and Goodman was remarkable.
It was remarkable for
still another reason.
In their campaign against the Sedition Act
Republicans had denounced the concept
of a federal common law
because it provided a lever
when fused with Hamilton's
coextensive powers doctrine
for the constructive amplification
of the powers of Congress.
They made an argument in
other words about federalism.
The new libertarians on the other hand
had denounced the concept
of a federal common law
because it provided a means for government
to do what it had no business of doing.
Of deploying the criminal law to subvert
freedom of the press and
hence the sovereignty
of the people, the first
principle of republicanism.
They made an argument
about individual rights.
But in Hudson and Goodwin Justice Johnson
did not breathe a word about rights
or a word about federalism.
The courts holding
hinged on public opinion
in the first instance and ultimately
on the separation of powers.
"The legislative authority of the Union
"must first make an act of crime.
"A fix of punishment to it and declare
"that the court shall have
jurisdiction of the offense,"
said Justice Johnson for the court
before it could become
cognizable in federal courts.
Now the problem with this sweeping holding
was that there were a great many offenses
over which no state
court had jurisdiction.
That now could not be
punished in the federal courts
unless Congress had acted.
And Congress had other
more important things to do
than specifying with precision the scope
of the federal criminal law.
Could somebody get away with
arson, bribery, extorsion
or grand theft committed on the high seas?
Or at federal installations
such as navy yards,
post offices, light houses
and the United States Mint?
The impossibility of such a
thing had been at the foundation
of the Federalist argument
concerning the federal
common law of crimes and for the closely
related argument pioneered by James Wilson
for the inherent powers of Congress.
And it came home to
roost in the great case
of United States and Coolidge.
An issue in the Coolidge case was an event
that occurred during the War of 1812.
American privateers
holding a letter of marque
authorizing them to seize enemy shipping.
Holding a letter of marque
from President Madison
seized a British vessel
in the North Atlantic
and started for an American port
where the vessel could
be liable as a prize.
They didn't make it home with their prize.
Because the second American vessel
captained by the defendant Coolidge
seized the British ship in open water
and beat the American privateers to port.
And so in 1813 the United States Attorney
for Massachusetts indicted Coolidge
at common law for grand
theft ship on the high seas.
He had to be indicted in federal court
because no state had
jurisdiction over a crime
that occurred on the high seas.
And so justice Joseph
story, a Madison appointee
believed that in this instance
the Federalist argument
about inherent federal
jurisdiction was sound.
And so he voted to sustain the indictment.
But his colleague, another
Republican appointee,
District Judge John Davis did not agree
and nor did the Supreme
Court which heard Coolidge
on the resulting certificate
of division in 1817.
Justice Johnson again spoke for the court
and he stuck to his guns.
"Offenses at common law did not exist
"in the courts of the United
States," he flatly stated
and as a result Coolidge walked.
His unmerited Liberty
was also a consequence
of the revolution of 1800.
What then about the Federalist
doctrine of inherent powers?
The claim that certain powers
that had not been enumerated
in the Constitution,
but which could not possibly be exercised
by the several states or any of them.
In which the law of nations established
as incident to all
national states necessarily
belong to the Congress
of the United States.
What happened to that
Federalist principle?
Well the answer of course
is that the Republicans
invoked that very principle
in support of their power
to acquire Louisiana in 1803.
Robert Livingston of
New York who negotiated
the Treaty of Session with France
denounced the doctrine of
inherent powers in 1798.
But broadcasted widely in
support of his treaty in 1803.
A great many other Republicans,
leading Republicans,
made the exact same conceptual somersault
between the one event and the other.
Jefferson's views were more complicated.
At the very outset of
the Louisiana treaty,
he presumed that a
constitutional amendment
could and should be adopted
that expressly authorized
the purchase of territory
from another national state.
"Let us not make blank
paper by construction,"
he wrote, one republican associate.
"Let us our peculiar
security is in the possession
"of a written constitution."
But as year 1803 wore on
Jefferson changed his tune.
And in a fascinating letter
to Wilson Carey Nicholas,
the junior member of the
Senate from Virginia,
Jefferson confessed now
while he thought it important
to set an example against
broad construction
by appealing for new power from the people
he was prepared to accept the treaty
without a constitutional amendment.
"The good sense of the country," he said,
"Will correct the evil of construction
"when it shall produce evil effects.
"But this evil construction was producing
"wonderful, wonderful effects."
This was the first time
in American history
when a professed strict constructionist
allowed reasons of state to trump
his own constitutional first principles.
And it would not be the last.
Now Republicans always
regarded the acquisition
of new territory, whether by purchase
or annexation as an exception
to the salutary principle
of strict construction generally
in opposition to the federalist doctrine
of inherent powers in particular.
In their judgment the robust form
of inherent powers
doctrine had been exploded
by the revolution of 1800.
But in the aftermath of the Civil War
an entire generation of
jurists shared the impulse
to extirpate from American
constitutional law,
every corollary of Antebellum
southern rights theory.
Much of which was
traceable to the Virginia
and Kentucky resolutions of 1798.
They were also inclined
to confirm the national
government's authority
to exercise every power
whether enumerated or
not, that was necessary
to maintain its very existence.
And the result was a revival
of inherent powers doctrine.
The revival climaxed in the
Supreme Court's 1889 decision
upholding the Chinese Exclusion Act.
Where Justice Stephen Field
speaking for unanimous court
explained that it didn't
matter that the Constitution
did not enumerate a power of Congress
to control the nation's borders
or to enumerated a power
to determine what person
should be denied entry
to the United States
and what persons should be admitted.
"These powers," said Field,
"Are inherent in the national government."
In support of the court's
ruling Field invoked
every single reason that
James Wilson had invoked
in the bank debate of 1781.
And the Federalists that invoked
in the Sedition Act debate of 1798.
Field might have added, though he didn't,
that in America constitutional revolutions
sometimes do go backward.
Time has come for me to conclude.
The stories I have told about
the Sedition Act of 1798
and the ramifications of Jefferson's
victory in the election of 1800,
established at least
two general propositions
about constitutional politics
and constitutional change
in American history.
First constitutional change rarely begins
in the Supreme Court.
Political movements often grounded
in distinctive constellations
of constitutional thought,
shape what public officials
do and why they do it.
Even public opinion
that most elusive thing,
modifies what the Constitution
means from time to time.
This is because
constitutional law is in part
a function of constitutional practice.
Which in turn reflects and reproduces
the conventions of constitutional thought
established by dominant
political coalition's.
Second, the process of constitutional
change seldom conforms
to the ideal typology.
Lawyers and political
scientists tend to use
in analyzing American constitutional law.
No offense Bob.
It is often said that
the basic building blocks
of constitutionalism in
America are protection
of individual rights,
the division of authority
between the national government
and the several state governments,
and the separation of
legislative, executive,
and judicial functions, and so they are.
But when constitutional
claims are contested
across the board as they were
in the Sedition Act controversy,
every domain of constitutional law
is eventually implicated.
It may take two or three decades or more
for courts and commentators
to work out every implication
of the constitutional upheaval at hand.
And in some instances the
process of consolidating
the results of one upheaval
may not have been completed
before the next upheaval begins.
All this is to say that
American constitutional law
has always been relatively
contingent on circumstances.
So much so that doctrines
presumed to be exploded
at one point in time have
made unexpected comebacks
at other points in time.
Woodrow Wilson, another statesman
from my adopted state
of Virginia once made
a similar observation with a phrase
that still seems exactly right.
"The Constitution of
the United States is not
"a mere lawyers document," he said.
"It is a vehicle of life and its spirit
"is always the spirit of the age."
Thanks for your patience.
(applause)
- Well thank you very much
that's a wonderful talk.
And I'm happy to say
that Professor Mccurdy
is gonna to take some questions.
Thank you.
- So do you request for
you to say a little more.
I'm interested in what
happens to the relationship
between the federal courts and common law
as the nation grows.
And I'm also wondering if you could say
a little more about this,
what seems like a rediscovery
of the Republican tradition
for Brennan and other
judges during the 1960's.
- The first question is what
happened to the relationship
between the common law and
the federal government's
power to prosecute crime.
In the aftermath of the
Sedition Act controversy
which in turn generate that
crazy case of Coolidge,
where the grand theft
ship guy walked, right?
You remember that the
Supreme Court justice
on circuit in that case
was Joseph's Story.
And Joseph Story spent
the next eight years
in a long correspondence with the senior
United States senator of Massachusetts,
his good buddy Daniel Webster.
They made a kind of parlor
game, it lasted eight years,
of trying to conjure up crimes
which should be cognizable
by the federal courts.
But Congress had not yet
defined them as a crime.
And the result is the first
codified federal statute
of crimes, known as
the Crimes Act of 1825.
It's only nine pages long.
So a federal crime bill in our time,
you need a hand truck to move it around.
But it was, it consisted of every crime
that they could imagine that had not been
yet specified by Congress.
And that took away the opportunity
for guys like Coolidge to
get away with grand theft
on the high seas with impunity.
Now there are other relationships
between the common law on the civil side
and the law of the United States,
that's a really long story.
Professor Schreiber said
that I once shared a prize
which I did with a very
good friend who teaches
the New York law school.
And he's written three
books on this issue.
The question of Swift and Tyson.
And the question of Erie and the--
Erie Railroad and was?
Tompkins yes.
Tompkins in the Erie Railroad
and it's an incredibly long complex.
And in the end (audience laughs)
not very exciting story.
The second question is what accounts
for Brennan's rediscovery
of the Jeffersonian
new libertarian tradition of 1800
as late as 1965 in New York
Times in Sullivan case.
And the answer is that at
issue in New York Times
and Sullivan was a editorial published
in the New York Times by Harry Belafonte
and a great number of
other African-American
intellectuals and activists.
That made a lot of denunciations
of what the Alabama police
had been doing in Birmingham.
And there was a lot of
stuff that was wrong.
Like they said the police
had encircled Alabama state.
Well God there was just a few
people I could see their gate.
And maybe somebody over on Hurst.
They hadn't completely encircled it.
So there were these errors of fact.
And that meant that they could
not rely on a truth defense.
And moreover the jury would have control
and these were 12 white guys listened
to a lawsuit filed by this guy Sullivan
who was on the Board of
Supervisors of Birmingham.
Now this was a slam dunk
that they were gonna
bring in a verdict of
liability and indeed,
I think New York Times
says total liability
at the time of that lawsuit
for that ad in various
state court decisions
was many millions of dollars.
So they needed to say that,
somebody need to make
a constitutional claim
that a private libel could
have such public consequences.
That it should be barred
by the First Amendment
of the Constitution of the United States.
And they hired a guy named Herbert Wexler
who made that argument.
And the way he did it was he said,
"The practical effects of
this lawsuit in Alabama
"are just like the practical effects
"of the Sedition Act
prosecutions the 1798."
And what he did was
link this Sedition crime
from the 18th century
to the 20th century reality of the 1960s.
And Brennan went for it.
Hook line and sinker and I think probably
had more fun writing that opinion
than he had writing any
other opinion he wrote
during his long and distinguished career
on the Supreme Court.
- Thank you very much Professor McCurdy.
Thank you all for being here
and enjoy the reception.
Thank you Charles.
(applause)
(gentle music)